unfortunately even though the list of  concerns about the behavior of marjorie  taylor green ethically and legally  continues to rise  the real solution is voting her out  she's in a very red district it doesn't  look like it's going to happen it's  horrifying i i'm with you it's  completely dystopian but it is just not  looking good and the best path forward  is uh to continue  maybe growing democratic control of the  house in 2022 as unlikely as that might  seem  and what can be done censure  she's already been stripped of committee  assignments i really don't know it's  actually one of the most frustrating  aspects of american government right now  that there seems to be very little in  the way of serious ways to hold people  accountable